[Music]
our top story at the bottom of the hour
the accused shooter and yesterday's
Florida School massacre made his first
court appearance this afternoon
19 year-old Nicholas Cruz is charged
with 17 counts of premeditated murder
many of those who survived are being
treated at a hospital in Pompano Beach
that's where we find she's national
correspondent ed Henry tonight with the
very latest good evening yet
Brett good evening if there's even a
tiny bit of good news tonight amid all
of this tragedy it's that there's only
one patient left in critical condition
tonight and that is really a miracle
given the triage that went on behind me
as the horror began playing out at
Stoneman Douglas High School the doctors
at Broward health North initiated a code
GREEN an all-hands-on-deck disaster
announcement they trained for just six
months ago
yet nothing fully prepared them for this
we kept on getting phone calls are you
ready to receive my patients are you
ready to take this yes the doctors here
believed there would have been far more
deaths but for the remarkable work of
the emergency personnel who stopped the
bleeding on so many wounds couple
minutes later I sense you realize like
wow this actually happened
real likely there was also the bravery
of one of the first victims who was
identified Aaron Feist an assistant
football coach and security guard who
used his own body as a human shield to
prevent more children from being shot we
had campus monitor who responded
immediately when there were signs of
trouble in the school unfortunately
those two heroes gave their lives for
our kids and probably helped prevent
this from being a worse tragedy it is
today students who survived the
bloodshed also give great credit to a
janitor who saved dozens of lives by
realizing that when the shooter pulled a
fire alarm a large group of barricaded
students were headed right at him as a
result of their heroic actions they
saved probably all of our lives about 40
of us the 19 year old shooter was
ordered held without bond after a brief
hearing are you Nicolas Jacob Cruz okay
sir you are charged with 17 counts of
premeditated murder meanwhile people in
this shattered Florida community tried
to come together with an afternoon vigil
to try to help ease the pain of so many
like this girl whose best friend was
shot right next to her unfortunately she
didn't make it now we should note this
is one of two hospitals in the Broward
Health System that helped out all told
when you combine both hospitals there's
that one patient I mentioned in critical
condition there's now seven patients in
fair condition and one tonight in good
condition so basically a tiny glimmer of
hope Brett that is good news ed Henry in
Pompano Beach ed thanks